joined now by governor scott walker of
course former governor wisconsin current
president
of yaf and we're very good friends with
uh with yaff
you know first of all governor thank you
thanks for joining us
my pleasure thanks for hanging out uh i
was just at it i
did a yaf event at ut austin
last week and uh it was really good
turnout of course we had a problem with
the coveted restrictions where they were
turning
you know the school was turning people
away and they wouldn't let us have
overflow
flow rooms and all that kind of stuff um
what are you are you worried that
you know with yaff that maybe these
schools have been given
a tool to uh restrict and shut down
events and they're gonna be
hesitant to give up that that that tool
in the future
well we're gonna have to watch to make
sure that whatever policies each campus
has are
are done uniformly you know a couple
years ago
one of your colleagues was at uc
berkeley
and uh through one of our yf events and
uh
they tried to effectively stop us from
happening they didn't put an outright
barrier but they
put a requirement it couldn't be after
three it couldn't
be advertised and most ridiculously they
weren't a charge
fees for us and the students there that
were three times
what they charged the left-leaning group
to have a u.s supreme court justice and
so we won
that case they had to settle so we're
going to be watching right now
obviously most left-wing groups are you
know sitting in their basement still
panicked
over something even a world filled with
people are vaccinated
so it's more likely a burden on
conservative voices but
we're going to make sure it's pushed
uniformly and if they don't we're going
to fight back just like we did at
berkeley
i'm also curious uh have you
do you think there's been it's kind of
hard to tell because of the covet
shutdown and everything and how that
plays into this but do you think the
left-wing activists
on campus have are you noticing any kind
of shift in tactics where they're
a little bit less likely to you know
have these
huge protests and a huge reaction they
used to have to conservative speakers
and are maybe smartening up a little bit
and and now now they realize well that
calls attention to it so instead we're
going to try to distract people or
shut down the voices another way
well smartening up and liberal activists
are never
words i would use together but yeah
they're aggressive i mean
um they're not on on campus with
speakers
in that regard right now but clearly you
know we've seen the hysteria
uh that they generate towards you know a
couple folks showing up an outdoor
barbecue without a mask on uh even when
uh
you know times have changed dramatically
in the last few months
and yet when they had these black lives
matters these other protest
universities for that matter
municipalities and others kind of giving
people a pass as though
covet only applies if you're right-wing
but if you're out promoting some radical
marxist cause it doesn't
um so i do think though there they are
still
pushing and i i would imagine you know
they'll be
future protests uh where the left will
be hypocritical as well
one minute not wanting to be out and
about without mask on socially distance
hovering away from others and the other
moment out raising a fist and defiance
to some other policy so
again it's one of those where uh campus
by campus we're going to be monitoring
that pushing back and making sure they
don't make us
live up to standards they're not
applying to those on the left yeah
absolutely
well i wanted to the main thing i want
to talk to you about as
as a former governor yourself um
it's been it's been an interesting year
for
governors in general republican
governors um
some of them with respect to the covid
lockdowns
i think have been quite impressive
obviously desantis in florida gnome and
south dakota and others
pushing back against it others other
other republican governors not not so
willing to uh to push back and have sort
of gone along with the so-called experts
and done whatever they
were told and then and then that kind of
gives way to
um this issue with gender we've seen a
push
across the country uh on a state
wide level of trying to pass
bills to kind of put a halt um
if if only temporarily to the march of
the left gender madness in their states
and so there's been bills uh banning
males from competing against females and
female sports
um and then in arkansas there was a bill
that was supposed to stop
uh children from having their genitals
mutilated
or being drugged you know because
they're gender-confused
but in both of those cases we know
governor noman south dakota and governor
hutchinson in
arkansas rejected or vetoed
those bills um and i first i'm just
broadly speaking i'm interested to get
your thoughts on that what
do you think there's is there any
defending this you know they had their
reasons they thought it was
government overstepping its bounds and
it was kind of a rejection of our
limited government principles and so on
um what's what's your take on that
no i don't think so i mean i think the
the fundamentals i tell kids on campus
all the time beyond just this
issue the difference between the left
and the right is the left wants the
government to tell you what to do when
to do and how to do it and everything in
every way
our view at least my view as i
articulate is
as long as you don't hurt the health and
safety of your neighbor go out and do
your own thing live your own life pursue
your own dream
in the larger context but we're talking
about minors that's a whole different
ballgame
there's the obvious reason why all
throughout society we have protections
for children for those under the age of
18. and so it only makes sense my kids
are now 25 and 26
i got nieces who are 17 and 14. i think
any of us who are parents
know particularly in the teen years how
our kids will change their mind 20 times
a day
uh let alone you know over the period of
a month or a year
or you know early on in their lifetime
so
i do think it makes sense that we're
protecting particularly against these
supposed woke
radical parents who are
allowing kids to go to great extremes to
try and show
how accepting they are not understanding
that
when you're talking about physical
changes when you're talking about things
involving
uh medical procedures medications other
things those are things that
are almost irreversible and again kids
are going to
change their minds on any number of
things
let's be careful what happens there and
on the larger context on
what happened in south dakota and what's
being proposed and advocated for in
other states
i think anyone who's ever watched
high school and junior high and even
earlier sports know
there's a reason why boys and girls
don't compete against each other
it wouldn't be fair there's other level
levels where
where young women are actually far ahead
their male counterparts when it comes to
their
development intellectually in the
classroom other areas
that boys will take some time to catch
up on but physically
it makes no sense for boys and girls to
be competing against each other
and no matter what you think about the
larger issue of transgenderism
the bottom line is there's no way that
someone who is physically born
a young man should be competing against
a girl and
i think governors of any party but
particularly republican governors
should recognize that stand up for that
yeah
on the on the sports part of it you know
one thing we're hearing from the left
now
is that well uh and then they're
trotting out their experts and they're
pulling out various studies and saying
oh it says here that
actually testosterone doesn't give you
any real advantage in sports
and that this is a perfect example of
what of how the left
of their tactic how they how they get
their their agenda through because
you know they're making a claim that is
number one false
of course obviously testosterone gives
you advantage but also basically
irrelevant because
um testosterone is only one
and one of the the less significant
advantages
that boys have i mean this this goes all
the way down to bone structure
muscle mass every you know every part of
us
is is if you're a man every part of you
is a man and uh so
there are dozens of biological
advantages and what they're trying to do
is
is is make it only about this one thing
testosterone
and then they start trying to confuse
the matter by saying oh well actually
testosterone doesn't always give you an
advantage
now on the on the issue of that the
logical pushback
yeah the logical pushback on that to me
it's a simple question back in return
saying so are are they advocating to end
women's sports uh because that's the
logical conclusion to that sort of uh
uh science uh not unscientific uh
argument that they're making is they're
saying well then they're making the case
for not having women and men
sports i think most of us regardless of
political or ideological belief would
say well that's ridiculous
well then they've kind of made our point
right exactly
how about uh why have a wnba in an mba
just get rid of the wnba
invite the women to come try out for the
nba teams and if they can make it then
uh then
you know we can all be together and be
one big happy family on
um specifically in arkansas uh so
there's the
the sports part of it which is important
but i think you'd probably agree i know
i certainly feel that
the drugging and mutilation of children
even more important than the sports
so i'm curious i know you can't read
anybody's mind but um
this it's it's so clear and so obvious
like of course you're going to pass a
bill protecting kids from this
and yet you have a republican governor
in the south
who says that's a bridge too far and is
now coming out effectively in favor of
mutilating and drugging kids what
do you have any theory on why he he or
any other republican would
come to that conclusion no i know asa i
mean is a good man overall
worked with him other things when i was
a governor and i liked governor gnome as
well it was obviously a different issue
just on the sports side of it things
but i think this is a classic example in
fact
our mutual friend michael knowles and i
were just talking about this in
preparation i read in advance his new
book and one of the problems he outlines
is
it's not just that conservatives aren't
fighting is that we seed the ground
we we see ground we don't just not
engage in the fight we see
ground with language and theory and i
think this is a prime example where uh
people like governor h hutchinson and
others seeding ground
not wanting to be discriminatory or
whatever phrase they might use
no that's not the case at all again if
someone is an adult i may not
initially like it or agree with it but
you know someone wants to be transgender
there
there's nothing that people are
advocating that as an adult
uh that they can't do that obviously
debates about where and
and how uh are certainly uh valid but
but this idea that with children i go
back to the point i was making before
that any of us who
were parents particularly we've had kids
go through their teenage years
know how frequently they change their
minds on issues here and
and i think having a certain level of
protection for the same reasons why
there's all sorts of other
protections written in state laws all
across the country
to protect the interests of of minors
it's why even at its core
the debate we have about protecting the
unborn because
an unborn baby is a human being
who cannot survive on its own without
protection and so
that's why in society we protect
whether the unborn or it's at any age
particularly up till 18 and then
obviously there's protections even for
adults
uh from violence and and the threats
from others but
but we particularly look at minors in a
unique way and i think it's
only makes sense that the lawmakers in
arkansas sought to do that as well
yeah i'm um you talk about kids not
being able to make choices what i always
say
is if you don't understand this concept
of kids not being able to
you know we shouldn't entrust kids with
these kind of choices like
try taking a six-year-old to
baskin-robbins
and telling him that he can get any
flavor ice cream he wants
and see how long it takes him to because
he's gonna he's gonna give you 14
different
answers and then collapse on the ground
in tears because you can't you can't
finally decide
uh that's that's kids they're indecisive
and we don't have you know your
prefrontal cortex which
controls discernment long-term planning
and all that that isn't fully online
until 25
so you know what what hope does a six or
seven year old have
i'm wondering um one one thing that was
mentioned you know by these
not just the republican governors but
oftentimes conservatives
when they're taking the the other side
of this issue
and saying well we don't want laws
banning
men from women's sports or we don't we
want laws dealing with uh with
transgender quote unquote medical care
they cite limited government and they
say you know our our fundamental
principle is conservatives there's
limited government and so that means the
government shouldn't get involved
this may be this may seem like a
heterodox opinion among a lot of
conservatives but
i'm increasingly starting to think that
maybe we need a better
slogan than limited government not
because i favor
big out of control government but
limited government
is such an ambiguous and vague sort of
term and i'm not really sure that the
problem is that government is
too big necessarily i think it's that
oftentimes government is doing the wrong
things and it's directing its power
in the wrong direction uh what do you
what do you think am i off on
on the wrong path here what do you think
no i think you're right i i i've said
for some time you know the people
absolutely love everything by the
government their people hate the
government
my view somewhere in between in the
sense i think government by and large
has gotten too big too expansive too
much part of our life
too much is pushed up to the federal
government whereas the founders intended
it
to be closer to the states and to the
people but that doesn't mean there isn't
a role
uh to play in government i like gov i
hate government that's too big
and ineffective and efficient what it
should do
is focus on the things that it should be
responsible for doing and then do it
well
which government historically has not
done and again protecting the difference
between what's right and what's wrong i
mean this is a very clear case
we know what's right and we know what is
wrong
it's worth protecting and again when
you're talking about a minor i
i don't think it's an overreach if if
not i mean to me again i go back to one
of the great things to do in debates
like this is ask people questions
just as we ask should women's sports be
gone and the question of the athletic
issue
similarly here the question should be
well if you you think you know this
is too much government so are they
advocating we get rid of all
laws and rules uh regarding children
that just let them decide if they want
to go to school or not
let them decide you know what else they
want to do with their life no
there are certain protections that are
put in place here and if the
people around these kids aren't smart
enough to say you know
you shouldn't be making these sorts of
decisions until you're an adult and then
you can decide on your own
then i think it's only right that the
government play a role in that regard
for the same reason we have all sorts of
other protections
and these are and as you point out kids
are not able to advocate for themselves
so some someone has to step up and
protect
there's a great video that went viral
last week of a
a mother at i think it was a georgia
school board meeting and um
she was speaking out against the mask
mandates and you know
little little kids at school six seven
hours a day you have to wear masks
no matter how young they are even though
they're obviously we know a very low
risk group
and she said you know i have to be here
advocating for
my child because he can't do it himself
and so that that's that's that is a role
where government should
step in if you've got a kid um whose
parents are bringing him in to be
mutilated or drugged
well he who's who's going to step the
government doesn't step in on his behalf
then who will that's that's the question
exactly right and we have a i mean just
remember this is part of a bigger
agenda by the left out there we have a
tip line at our website yaf.org yf.org
tips people can see our campus tip line
most of our tips as you can imagine
are things about wild left-wing
professors and
sadly increasingly stories of
segregation on campus
uh not not what we thought of in the 60s
and the 50s before that but
but these weird sorts of segregated
things on training or graduation or
other issues
but one of the tips came from iowa state
not not from the coast
but from the middle of the country where
they gave us a tip not about their
campus in college but
the local school district in ames iowa
who partnered with blm for a week of
action
during february for black history month
had literally nothing to do with black
history and instead
was this radical indoctrination
curriculum that started from preschool
to 12th grade
where preschoolers and kindergartners
were actually giving coloring pages
with transgender figures and told that
they could
decide whether they wanted to pick to be
a boy or girl or somewhere in between
this is just wrong this is just
fundamentally wrong not only on the
premise itself but the idea that they're
introducing this at that young of an age
but that should be an eye-opener to
everyone listening and watching
that this is how far the left is seeking
to go
we have to expose that push back on that
because if they can be doing it at ames
iowa
they can be pushing this anywhere in
america right that's that's the thing
i think still a lot of conservatives
like to think that this is
regulated to the crazy coastlines but no
this this this stuff is everywhere both
gender
and race it's um the left agenda in both
in both of those areas it's it's it's
everywhere
now um i did want to ask you about
uh the new yaf campaign called the long
game
and this sounds exactly in line with
what i'm always preaching about so i'm
i'm happy to hear about it but could you
explain what
what it is exactly and what the what the
purpose is
yeah it fits in actually very well what
we were just talking about seeing just
how far the left has gone
uh this didn't happen overnight we're
under siege in america in our schools
and our college campuses
heck in our culture even in our
communications with the
censorship we increasingly see from big
tech all these things didn't happen
yesterday they've been at this for
decades you go back to saulinski's
work and writings back in the 1960s they
have systematically
tried to take over our colleges and
universities they've seeped into our
schools
we see this all throughout the
curriculum and so my argument is
not that we see the battles of today
we've got to be involved in every one of
those
for sure but that we have to have a long
game approach
to retake major parts of our culture
our schools our colleges our
universities our communications
and so we spell out in fact if people
want a free copy we'll send it to you
yaf.org
long game it's a 12 point action plan
not only expand our scope and our reach
and our college campuses to get to every
campus and every student
across america to step up our free
speech efforts
for what we were just talking about in
terms of college administrators and
student government officials trying to
block conservative thought through
cancer culture on campus
but also to go younger ages to not only
go into high school
now to aggressively go into junior high
and where necessary
like that example i gives in ames iowa
to
to go out and support the parents of
even elementary school students
to give them a counter not just to that
radical uh transgender coloring pages we
just talked about
but increasingly this whole 1619 project
and
all these programs in curriculum that
are teaching our children to hate
america we need to counter that
the good news is our data our research
shows that
as liberal or progressive as students
are today
particularly in high school and college
if we just give them access to
basic facts the basic information that's
countered and what they've been hearing
they dramatically shift our direction
and so that's why the left's pushing
cancel culture
and that's why we've got a long game to
push back so i know i know you'd
describe all this on the website but
what when we talk about the education
system specifically
and especially in the younger ages k
through 12.
um i tend i i tend to take a more
um doomsaying approach on this and
really all issues but especially the
education system i i
i tend to think there is i don't know if
there's any way to take it back it's
just so fundamentally
you know the the left-wing agenda is is
so fundamentally ingrained
in um the public school system i don't
know if there's a way to do it
do you think there is a way to to
actually you know even in
from a long term obviously it's not
something we do overnight but
do you think there's actually a way to
take the that education system back
why i do and i think it's in stages i'm
obviously an optimist uh
but but i'm a realist as well so i'm not
naive to what we're facing it's a huge
block out there and more than just the
entrenched indoctrination we see in
colleges and now increasingly
in our government-run schools for sure
but the bigger concern i have
immediately is just
literally this cancel culture it's not
just liberal bias it's not just
political correctness it's
it's wiping out not only amongst
professors and educators but even
amongst fellow students
the ability to even speak out and have a
counter opinion
to this radical woke agenda that's out
there so first and foremost
it's why a big part of our long game
plan is to aggressively step up our
efforts
work with partners like alliance
defending freedom to push and advocate
for free speech to win cases like we did
at uc berkeley and elsewhere
but even go not just on college campuses
but into our schools
so that conservative voices whether
speakers students
parents and others don't get shut down
that's the first step because
again the data we've shown we just
released a poll
about a week ago that showed on a number
of key issues that when we
introduce facts when people start to
hear when young people
students particularly start to hear the
facts there's a dramatic shift out there
so that's the first step the other part
of it is
again getting to every campus
in high school it's it's being able to
organize and get information out it's
even simple things like
stepping up our youtube efforts because
our data overwhelmingly shows
the number one way young people get
their information uh
isn't the way the media in many cases
think with twitter
i mean there's some of that but it's
overwhelmingly youtube and so whether
it's you
it's shapiro it's knowles it's alicia
krauss it's
rachel campbell's duffy or katie pavlich
whoever we have speaking on campuses
getting that content up on our youtube
page promoting that
growing from about a half a million
subscribers we have now over five
million is our goal
with one billion views of our content we
know there's ways of getting around
the indoctrination that people are
getting in their schools and then
another interesting point that we
include
is not only student but providing a
network
for educators for teachers and
professors not only conservative ones
but there's a
a really significant number of educators
who just want to teach the facts
but they're so overwhelmed by their
colleagues they're so overwhelmed
by the bias they see in their curriculum
guidelines and their textbooks
that we need to provide assistance to
correct that as well
so it'll happen but not overnight yeah
well i i think this is the right
approach i'm happy that you're
focusing on on the long haul i think
often times as conservatives we're
looking for you know the the quick win
we're we're looking for that at most a
one two three step plan do that that
that and everything's better
and it's just not gonna work that way
but it's this is this is a fight we have
to be willing to to fight over the
course of
you know generations really so i
appreciate your efforts and uh thanks
for for joining us today governor walker
my pleasure good to be with you thanks
thank you
you